blois vue du château une vue royal
réservé historiquement aux nobles qui
domine le territoire à l'opposé sur la
rive droite un quartier regard de la
ville c'est le quartier viennent tout
l'opposé la cité royale inondable non
fortifiée populaire ils viennent est un
territoire qui vit 2 et par la loi
emmanuel vion viennent elle est
responsable du service ville d'art et
d'histoire de blois
c'est un quartier qui du coup a
développé certains métiers qui forcément
sont en lien avec la loi donc les
mariniers puisque il y avait par exemple
à la chapelle des mariniers à saint
saturnin
il y avait les auberges puisque c'est le
thé la porte d'entrée de blois donc
c'était forcément des métiers qui se
rassembler dans ce quartier qui était
populaire donc et le quartier a gardé ce
caractère populaire il faut pas oublier
que le bois en fait et le quartier
vienne était un peu un centre
névralgique de commerce
donc là on est sur la route entre
chartres et bouge
et puis on avait un autre axe de
communication qui était le fleuve entre
orléans et tours donc du coup c'était
vraiment un point stratégique où il y
avait beaucoup de passage et cette rue
était très fréquenté à l'époque
médiévale vraisemblablement mené à
l'époque gallo-romaine vienne traversera
les époques en fief indépendant jusqu'au
xviie siècle où le quartier intègre
blois domaine royal
c'est un quartier qui vit qui est très
éclectique dans dans son architecture
c'est vrai qu'on va retrouver vraiment
d'époque différents le moyen-âge à coup
tu m'aimes l'époque moderne
donc ça peut surprendre parce qu'il n'y
a pas d'unité mais en même temps ça
montre aussi la richesse de son histoire
il ya des belles demeures en 40 ans car
s'ils viennent ça en oublie mais en fait
il ya eu des bourgeois qui sont venus
s'installer dans ce quartier au 19e
siècle
aum
tous
au xviiie siècle une débâcle emporte le
pont médiéval rapidement a construit le
pont wilson puis l'avenue wilson saint
gervais celle-ci large couple quartier
viennent en deux une partie médiévale
renaissance et une partie plus investis
ou 19e siècle ce côté là du quartier
c'est plutôt développé avec l'industrie
est en fait les maisons qui sont ici ont
été construites par le directeur de
cette entreprise et c'était pour les
ouvriers et c'est vrai que là on est au
tout début du 20e siècle mais on ressent
une préfabrication déjà un petit peu ce
qu'on va retrouver ensuite dans les
zones pavillonnaires
mais ce qui est aussi intéressant dans
ces maisons c'est ce qu'on voit c'est
que vous avez au rez-de-chaussée une
entrée le garage mais par contre on
commence à y vivre dans la maison au
premier étage
alors pourquoi mais parce qu on se
souvient des inondations et du coup le
fait de vivre au premier étage ça permet
quand même déjà de se protéger un petit
peu vienne a toujours été en proie aux
inondations
les protections alentours le prouve mais
viennent à bénéficier aussi des
alluvions de la loire enrichissant la
terre jusqu'au milieu du xxème siècle le
maraîchage fut une activité forte vienne
tire peut-être son identité de son
indépendance et de ses vertus
nourricière j'ai compris que le
caractère du quartier devienne avait
quelque chose de plus peut-être que
d'autres quartiers les gens avaient une
certaine fierté des gens n'étaient de
l'autre côté de la loire par rapport à
la ville on n'avait pas on n'avait pas
toutes les commodités qu'avaient les
gens centre ville non vivait bien
on était en fait des gens de la campagne
à la ville
vienne attire à nouveau habité blois
rive gauche au calme à cinq minutes du
centre ville et tendance
et puis traversé par la loire à vélo les
bords de loire en plein aménagement de
gaines une halte agréable face à la cité
royale
alors si vous passez par là sachez aussi
vous perdre dans ce paysage entre
ruralité et urbanité